within about 30 minutes of us making
that phone call
the whole of the area where we were was
infested with stasi vehicles
so it was clear to us that the phones
were all tapped to the british embassy
[Music]
i used to be part of a military
intelligence gathering unit
working in the former east germany so
bricksmiths or the
british commander-in-chief's military
mission
was an organisation brought to to
be into being at the end of the second
world war
when the soviets and the americans
the british and the french decided to
partition germany as occupying forces
we were there to pass messages between
the soviets and the west however that
was the over
role of the mission the covert role of
the mission
was to gather as much intelligence as
possible what was your role in operation
i was the tour nco at times and my job
was to map read get us to where we
needed to go
and then report using a dictaphone
everything that i saw and also in the
tour officer
who sat in the back and his job was to
take all the photography
it wasn't uncommon for one of our
vehicles
to be followed by up to 10
secret police vehicles one of the
operations we did which was
at the time was was a very secretive
operation
was one called operation tomahawk which
was the
systematic scavenging of
soviet rubbish dumps um and most of
these dumps were quite close to their
barracks
where they where all the troops were and
so we had to carry out this activity
in the dead of night historically
between about
two and four o'clock in the morning it
certainly got the heart going because
you had to leave the vehicle about two
to three hundred meters
away from it and then walk in imagine
you know a forty to fifty foot high
wall of rubbish i mean everything from
garden waste to toilet disposal
the other thing that really got the
blood going was the fact that these
rubbish dumps were also occupied
by every piece of vermin that you could
think of
they were alive with rats and i always
remember once looking with my
infrared goggles across a rubbish
dump and it was like heaving you know
packs of wild dogs as well which were
all rabid used to roam on these
on these sites and and some of the dumps
that we looked at as well of course
were behind military hospitals you know
if they cut off a limb
you know an arm or a leg or something
like that they would throw it over the
barrett wall
into the rubbish dump for some reason
known only to the soviets
they didn't really use toilet paper and
so therefore they would
wipe themselves on letters from home
uh documents anything i mean it was just
incredible to us but very natural to
them and luckily for us they would then
throw that over
onto the rubbish dumps and we would just
spend two to three hours buried
in the rubbish selecting bits of paper
again
other words we learned were secret in
russian and things
so you could pick a document up and see
whether it was confidential or
whatever and then gather it put it into
your sack
which was an east german sack so that
again if we had to discard it
um nobody ever knew that it was you was
there
a new tank had been introduced in the
80s
into east germany called the t-80 tank
and we had no idea what the inside of it
looked like
and luckily one night one of our guys
found
like wall charts which showed the entire
mechanism
where possible and whenever possible we
would steal stuff
i just saw this soldier who was asleep
by a tree
and his pack was was next to him
and again we always wanted to know these
detailed things like
what did the soviet soldier how did they
operate how did they compare to our
soldiers in the west
so it just seemed to me that if i took
his rucksack
apart from feeling about a second's
worth of sorry for him because it was
cold
and i knew he wouldn't have anything so
i i crept out the vehicle
grabbed it you know what we learned very
quickly or
confirmed was just how much emphasis
they put on their nuclear biological
and chemical warfare kit his complete
oversuit
and his respirator and his canister
and and apart from that virtually
nothing all
my new bits of intelligence which when
you put it together in a jigsaw
gave our intelligence community the
picture of what we were facing
can you tell us about the time you felt
most in danger
there was a particular occasion when
when i was out on tour
and again another high intelligence
collection priority
was this particular soviet vehicle
because this vehicle's job was to come
to the banks of the
river elbow or one of for river
crossings and it would literally drive
off the bank
into the into the river under water
and survey the and survey the um
the riverbed so that their tanks could
come up
fit their snorkel devices and then drive
across the riverbeds
and we heard it going around on driver
training in this wooded area
so me and the tour officer got out the
vehicle we left the vehicle where we
thought hidden
and and went across about 100 or so
meters from the vehicle
into a little clump of bushes uh to get
close-up photography of this of this
vehicle going around doing driver
training
unfortunately for us the stars he knew
knew we were in this area
and the soviets were alerted the troops
that were doing the driver training
and one of their vehicles saw our
vehicle
and and basically rushed it to try and
block it in
our driver thinking on his feet
in order to not show them where we were
because we were out of the vehicle
he drove the vehicle off at high speed
therefore taking them all away with them
and uh and left us two sitting in the
in the bush this was it in snowy
conditions it was deep snow on the
ground
we had no communications on the vehicle
whatsoever
so we went to a local village uh by this
time it was dark about nine o'clock in
the evening
and we we went to this guest house
knocked on the door
and a little opened it looked at us
and it was the pub landlord and and very
kindly he took pity on us he let us into
the pub
we were able to make a phone call to the
british embassy in berlin
um within about 30 minutes of us making
that phone call
the whole of the area where we were was
infested with stasi vehicles
so it was clear to us that the phones
were all tapped uh to the british
embassy
we knew the penalties that the pub
landlord would have to pay so we had a
quick drink with him
left his establishment and went and hid
in a bus shelter on the edge of the
village
and we were on we were on the run on our
own for about 12 hours
what would you say are some common
misconceptions about working in
espionage
always being surrounded by gorgeous
women and and
offers to take you to bed you know that
that never happened and and the idea
that it's a very glamorous
you know scavenging on rubbish dumps was
not a uh
a very pleasant experience to say the
least
do you miss it like everything in life
yeah could we turn the clock back
would i would i go back and do anything
different no i wouldn't change anything
you know i had 32 good years in the in
the military
where you know you're doing something
against your enemy and getting away with
it
uh was was tremendously rewarding
but i guess i guess the thing looking
back now is of course everybody knew
where they were
in life you know we knew where the enemy
was and we knew where we were
and we all had that understanding you
know nowadays of course
we don't know where the enemy is they're
all around us you know and um
and so this asymmetric warfare type
scenario now where there is no front
line
it can be around you behind you i think
now it's
it's a lot more dangerous than it was
back then
my next bit of kit not necessarily going
to be that obvious
but it's a phone i had a very well-known
hollywood celebrity that was single
so it was very handy to give him one of
these with a pay-as-you-go sim
which made his life a lot easier if he
was giving out his numbers
to new friends